en sarre rapport du csa publiée par
télérama en début de semaine nos amis on
a appris qu'elle était les émissions et
les séquences les plus signalés par les
téléspectateurs en 2019 alors en
première position
il y à la sortie de christine angot chez
laurent ruquier sur l'espionnage
donc c'est laurent ruquier qui est
numéro 1 et 10 alors le classement c'est
quoi en numéro 2 c'est lci la matinale
chronique sur le salaire des enseignants
numéro 3c nous voilà face à l'info
profonde propre d'eric zemmour sur le
général bugeaud numéro 4 s'est france
inter par jupiter chansons de frédéric
fromet elle a cramé la cathédrale où un
médecin numéro cinq et lci
retransmission du discours d'eric
zemmour à la convention de la droite et
numéro six touche pas à mon poste on est
numéro 6 ah ouais ben aller mieux dans
les audiences
regarder les audiences en prime au
regard des plaisanteries de l'humoriste
jean marie bigard sur le viol d'une
patiente par son médecin
voilà donc on est numéro 6 alors bien
sûr il ya eu des dizaines d'articles
malhonnêtes qui disent que je suis dans
le top alors qu'on a on n'a rien fait du
tout voilà regarder quand christine
angot dérape dans l'émission de laurent
ruquier on met la tête de christine
angot vous allez voir regarder voilà et
quand voilà mais quand c'est jean marie
bigard qui fait une vague bien sûr dans
mon émission mais votre père mais ma
tête voilà comme d'habitude et le
huffington post le titre comme
d'habitude sont très sympathiques
cyril hanouna n'arrive qu'en sixième
place les gars ils sont limite des
suprêmes voilà de ma seizième place
voilà le huffington post le voilà
toujours aussi bon un brin entendue
finalement pdg ni une fois de plus voilà
heureusement que je ne nie pas cette
merde
les chiffres ont parlé de laurent
ruquier parce que c'est vrai qu' on
n'est pas couché baisse en audience même
si ça reste autour de 800 milles et il
ya une blague qui est vraiment dérangé
samedi dernier c'est laurent ruquier
café in black sur le une vanne sur le
grand chef paul bocuse qui est décédé il
y a deux ans et savane n'est pas passé
du tout puisque il faisait allusion au
suicide du chef bernard loiseau qui
avait perdu ses trois étoiles au
michelin regarde du moment le restaurant
de paul bocuse qui a perdu sa troisième
étoile au michelin en même temps force
est de reconnaître qu'il cuisine
beaucoup moins bien depuis deux ans
qu'il est décédé au moins l'avantagé
avec baucus et qu'on peut lui retirer
ses étoiles sans avoir peur qu'ils se
suicident la famille bocuse serait tout
de même évidemment remonté contre le
guide
là nous dit on alors est ce que ça vous
choque vous cette blague et nous quoi
vous aimez c'est incroyable de sortir
une blague paraît ce jeudi est enfin ça
n'a aucun sens en fait pour moi c'est
vraiment véritablement attention je
pense qu'il a dérapé je sais pas si il
présentera ses excuses mais il devrait
en tout cas il n'y a pas eu de temps de
signalement que ça là dessus je vous le
dis ah oui j'ai envie qu'ils en prennent
quand même de faire une
sonova son humour qui apparaît sur le
suicide d'un homme quand même qui à bout
comme ça ces suicides en pleine nuit
descente femmes et des enfants
et là en disant que bocuse qui est déjà
mort envahisse il fait une blague sur un
mort en parlant d'un suscite ex pensais
qu'ils auraient dû couper cette blague
et j'aurais dû la coupe est évidemment
surtout qu' il n'est pas possible que le
chef actuel du restant sous la cuisine
se fait pas tout seul
lui il prêtait peut-être dans un état
psychologique très faible et vous me
dire ça c'est la blague que non j'ai pas
d'accord à la blague de mauvais goût
mais ce qu'il est ce qu'il était en
train de dire en tout cas c'est qu'il
est en train de signaler un système qui
devient aberrant le système des étoiles
et ses amis font en sorte qu'ils années
d'oppression voilà énoncés on vous
donner un exemple pour vous donner un
exemple
et si nous regarde je sais pas si je
sais pas s'il va contredire ou pas mais
pour donner un exemple jean françois
piège que sur m6 qui mérité trois
étoiles et tout le monde le dit pas
qu'il n'est plus est détesté par pas le
plus aimé du ca est détesté par tout le
groupe et par tous ceux qui donnent les
étoiles on lui donnera jamais sa
troisième étoile
parce qu'il est détesté et parce que ça
c'était comme ça c'est la cooptation et
tout ça et c'est vrai que des gens que
ça mais dans des embarras incroyable
speed est ce qu'ils dénoncent un petit
peu c'est qu'aujourd'hui on sait que ce
système des étoiles il faut des buts
pour pas le savoir c'est quand même
copinage et compagnie et que ça des
conséquences énormes